- I'll be the first to admit
that sometimes litigation is bananas.
And such was the case in the
Epic versus Apple litigation
that's going forward right now,
when the parties had to discuss
one of the "Fortnite" characters, Peely,
who happens to be a banana
and things got hilarious from there.
A lawyer for Apple introduced the issue,
"We have a large yellow
banana here in a tuxedo?"
and the witness replies,
"Yes, that's Peely."
The Apple lawyer says, "We
thought it was better to go
with a suit instead of the naked banana
because we're in federal court right now."
And then the Epic lawyer chimes in,
"There might've been an
implication that showing Peely
without a suit might've
been inappropriate.
Is there anything inappropriate
about Peely without clothes?"
To which witness replied,
"It's just a banana, ma'am."
Because sometimes it's just a banana.
Now I'm sure that this is
not the last we've heard
of this banana because this
case is surely to be appealed
unless it gets too slippery.